- I was a drug dealer,
and I got incarcerated.
When I came out, I was like
there's no way I'm gonna
get a second chance or get a job.
I'm trying to achieve and running
is part of my way of getting there.
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible by
Dignity Health. Hello, humankindness.
(soft piano music)
- My name is Manuel Navarro, and I am
a runner with Back On My Feet.
Back On My Feet is an organization
that helps people fight homelessness;
and at this point in my life,
the lowest point in my
life, that's where I'm at;
and it's helping me be successful
and achieve everything I
wanna achieve the right way.
- My name is Pete Roller,
and I'm a volunteer
and board member with Back On My Feet.
Manny and I have been running
together for nine months.
We run three mornings a
week at 5:45 in the morning.
Back On My Feet is a national non-profit
that works with individuals who are
experiencing homelessness
or in some stage of recovery
and provides a hand up
to employment and housing
and independence through
community and fitness.
Running is a really nice complement
to recovery for many of our members.
Running, in particular,
provides the physical release.
For a lot of us, we're
replacing negativity.
Those three mornings a
week are the three mornings
where they know they can
come and be supported
by the rest of the group
and really feel good
about themselves because
whatever comes in between that
is gonna be much harder;
and Back On My Feet provides
the link for them to successfully
continue that recovery.
I know it works because the changes
in the individuals,
members, volunteers, myself
are visible, and they're tangible.
For our members, it allows
them to feel human again,
and I've seen countless
members just blossom.
When they come to the morning circle,
they're just another runner.
- [Volunteer In Black] Who are we?
- [Group] Back On My Feet.
- Where we from?
- [Group] San Francisco.
- How far we gonna run?
- [Group] Forever.
- I hated running, but now I love running.
I mean, just the community;
they make you feel very welcome.
They're really there to help you,
to embrace you and to
support the fact that
you're trying to be successful in life
and trying to do something right.
And the connection that me
and Pete have is amazing.
I never had real friends before.
In the drug business
you don't trust anybody,
and here I am trusting.
He's always telling me
how I could do better
and pushing me to do
better and that's good
because he's there to support me,
and I think we all
deserve a second chance,
and I'm taking it.
(intense music)